[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talked about one keep
forgetting that I get interests like
have a second like oh who oh wait have
you guys ever gotten a root canal just
going this way to get one how do you all
really hasn't done what's that you're
talking right now
odd that I don't sound like no I said I
can hear myself sound it sounding SS
Larry right now thank you I can hear it
Oh so what happened what is it like is
your mouth this is why I think you
should always get a second opinion for
about a year or two now I've been
feeling this cavity because every time I
hit hit the back of my mouth with a fork
I'd feel every single time right every
single time and then let's go see my
dentist who was my mom's dentist I think
this was to always part of retired
because he didn't diagnose me correctly
but he was poking around and he's like
oh no I don't have a cavity you're
perfectly fine all right cool and then I
went to some like a brand dealer dentist
that they clean my teeth look good and
then I was like oh it also hurts back
there and this guy also poked around oh
you're good okay cool and then but it's
been hurting more and more in this week
it was throbbing like my whole jaw was
dropped to the point where I had to take
ibuprofen to go to sleep and like I'd be
like laying in bed and then five minutes
and I'm like oh I can't fall asleep and
so I'm like I have to go see a dentist
so geo scheduled a dentist appointment
with a new one with the new one
unless it's workout lady that's like
atmosphere yeah and then we got an x-ray
he goes dude this shit's [ __ ] up you
have a crazy cavity and the content is a
different guy we found a brand new
a third one I think it's a second
opinions don't work the third opinions
do you matches your dentists and usually
see us oh yeah because I kept thinking
since both dentists already said there's
no cavity I was like it can't be that
[ __ ] wack yes I was like I think up
my wisdom teeth growing in and I think
it's causing the throttle mouth no no
and then he was like or it could be a
rowdy nerf and I'm like huh oh yeah you
have a cavity and you have a rowdy nerve
and it's been there he's like I can
clearly tell it's been there for over a
year
no way so yesterday they had to get like
this metal thing and like stick it down
your roof and the first part where they
only injected anesthesia in like three
places so my whole mouth is no my talk
like this and then when they finally
went in with the needle I'm oh [ __ ] and
he goes oh I gotta numb that part too he
already hit all the spots but then every
time we would tell me everyone's
different so if you feel pain let me
know cuz I gotta put it what do you do
did you squeeze his hand like ah you
told me to put your finger up feel it on
like your child yeah yeah yeah it's like
how does that even happen it's like a
[ __ ] kung fu acupuncture technique I
hate your [ __ ] it hits your tooth and
all of a sudden your ankle hurts yeah
but he drilled the holes in he cleaned
it all up you put medication in there
it's good now I got antibiotics and I
have motrin and then how long did it
take cuz I gotta get mine done too
it took an hour a good hour okay I have
to go get your the dentist yeah okay
because I recommend this guy I really
like this your des oh I've always had
bad Dan says he poked your nerve no no
he was he was testing it I really like
I've had a dentist that called me a
[ __ ] because I was like we're not in
English but video means but basically
called oh wow
okay for like feeling so much pain I
reminds insides don't let me doubt what
I was like I don't think I don't think
the the numbing stuff work yeah because
he came back and he was like yeah this
just it's just in your head or whatever
yeah and then started numbing out no
this guy was cool cuz he was like shut
up I gotta work I pretty much was like
letting me know if it's painful that's
not the right way I shouldn't be feeling
pain so he wanted to make sure
everything was numb and good before and
when they were taking out my wisdom
teeth like because I got all four taken
out at the same time me too I was ma20
cuz I need to get mine out I think 19 or
20 effort it felt good but I took them
out before getting braces and then they
also took out two teeth so anyway wait
they took out two teeth like a vampire
yeah you got two missing teeth yes I
stick out for what yes well yeah because
of crowding over but now I wish they
didn't do it and I wish they would have
just not been lazy come calling that
lazy even though they're professionals I
don't know but because when I like when
I rest my tongue all the way in the roof
of my mouth it like spills out so I feel
like if I had those those two teeth that
I had you will be a snug yeah it would
be snug is it the problem with the
wisdom tooth though it can like croucher
I push her other teeth out of place yeah
that's what was [ __ ] up mine it was
hurting so bad and it's because it was
pinching my gum against my other tooth
so I was like I gotta get these out
please two bottom ones are somewhat
coming out halfway so that I don't like
that I know there's a little flap of gum
over it yes so food get stuck underneath
don't get infected yeah you know I know
I had a hole in the bottom what is this
left bottom left hand back that wisdom
tooth there was a huge hole for like
months and I kept getting a whole bunch
of food stuck in there after they took
out the wisdom teeth but that particular
one too though when they were actually
doing the surgery I kept telling him
like I could feel like him
like I could really feel it and he put
like five different like extra shots in
there cuz it was only local anesthesia
they don't put me under and I was just
like it hurts it really hurt but he just
kept he's like listen I don't know what
it was like yes we'll hook me up by the
time he was done with the anesthesia I
couldn't feel anything
yeah so I have surgery to where like so
I'm missing the tooth man the front
bottom his sisters are here and they dig
drill though they drill that thing in
there that's an implant right the
implanted implant yeah I need to wait
for it to heal and they're gonna finally
put the crown on to make a little eye
cat tooth worn with the missing spot in
his jaw like yeah I was like missing
bone yeah so that the difficulty with
this is that since there was no usage at
that area there's like very little
foundation so so the past like half a
year now like I've just been going in
for surgeries for them to like develop
the site to have more foundation and
stuff your kids are gonna be perfect
your missing teeth your extra teeth man
sir this part of it like the doctor was
like alright cool so we're gonna I'm
about to spray some water in here and
it's gonna get a little wet so don't
mind the wetness I was like in my mind I
was like have you been spraying my mouth
with water cuz it's like drying out
every once in a while and then the next
thing I know if he turns to this machine
I was like that was like well that's a
funny water sounding thing whatever that
is and then and he just starts going in
and then it just starts splattering
everywhere must inside my mouth I was
like sure that it's a lot of [ __ ]
water and then the next thing I'm like
well hold on hold on a second they don't
have warm water oh no no it's like
excessive why is usually cold then so
then this is
it was have you choked on that cuz when
I was getting my wisdom teeth removed
it's probably so much [ __ ] blood then
you could feel it dripping down to your
dollies
this guy swallow yeah they get that
[ __ ] then they get that sucker
anything you still have that little
[ __ ] drop that just stays in there
and you're like should I [ __ ] just
swallow it [ __ ] I'm just gonna swallow
it the mold for your braces that [ __ ]
I'm like so just like a [ __ ] doorstop
that goes between her two teeth right
yeah yeah okay and then he has like this
rubber balloon [ __ ] that goes over my
face and I'm like what if I had like
Mexican food and I needed go diarrhea
I'll be like that thing about me I
learned this when I was a kid was my
body doesn't take anesthesia well like
local lidocaine well I need extra
because when I was a kid he like put
like three or four injections wait a
little babies that can you still feel
like yeah I could
oh [ __ ] and they would like keep on
filling me up with more and then I felt
one stop keeping that door open during
lunch I know they always come in during
lunch but I can still feel so he
injected more and then I felt like I
should paint like a sharp of my nose and
then my nose went numb right your wit
numb and then I remember like a couple
years ago I went go get fillers done and
like they kind of I can feel what's
fillers like injections okay um they had
to fill me oh no no this was a dentist
also he had Sofia is so much lidocaine
cuz I kept on feeling it but I started
puffing out because it was so much
liquid oh my god I was like I still feel
it he's like okay like it's bad is there
another drug you're supposed to use it
you wonder I know so now whenever
anything up in some no that's a we
weren't dangerous I don't care it under
general general anesthesia I'd rather
you put this you guys ever lied to the
doctor when they go does that hurt and
you're like no cuz you don't wanna be a
little [ __ ] no I actually exaggerated
know like when having Isaac if I had a
c-section right and they gave me the
spinal tap so from the waist down
everything goes numb and when it was
time to start the doctor told me he's
like alright I'm gonna I'm gonna like
poke around a little bit and let me know
if you feel anything
this fool would run where he was
actually opening me up and he was like
do you feel that and I was like um no
he's like okay
we were totally [ __ ] them cuz he
literally like opened me up when you
well he [ __ ] stabbed you first then
did you feel no because you know what I
think what he was doing Wow are you
seeing is like I think my assumption is
that he first Pope before he said
anything and then he told me all right
I'm gonna tell Jodi okay I'm assuming
she was like okay oh [ __ ] I mean I I
guess it's like you got to do it over
time and you get used to it but I feel
like that's the same thing I can do
toward a fish but I cannot do maybe with
a whole like dressing a whole like like
a cow or something yeah I don't know if
I could do it yet but I think I could
get used to it cuz fish don't make any
sounds or show me you know what people
get used to feeling more financially
secure especially the during these
economically turbulent times so if
you're still needlessly throwing money
every month at high interest credit card
decks and there's a lot people out there
like that it's time you checked out
upstart it's the revolutionary online
lending platform that knows you're more
than just a credit score see apps
learning now is the time to find out how
lower your up star rate can be to help
pay off high-interest credit card
unlike other lenders upstart can reward
you based on your education and job
history in the form of a smarter rate
you don't need a degree or diploma to
apply though I'm sorry let you skip
going to the bank because it's
completely online they offer loans from
1000 a $50,000 so you can consolidate
your dough their debt into one easy
fixed-rate payment upstart makes it fast
and simple to check your rate since it's
just a soft pool it won't affect your
credit score the hard pool happens if
you accept your rate and proceed with
your application and the best part if
the loan is a prove them accepted most
people get their funds the very nice
over 400,000 people have used up start
to pay off credit cards or meet their
financial goals Wow so free yourself my
burden of high interest credit card debt
and get back to use your money your way
with upstarts no worse okay guys now see
why upstart has a four point nine out of
five rating on Trustpilot and hurry up
to upstart dot-com slash record to find
out how low your upstart rate can be
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes
that's upstart dot-com slash record what
I hate to sometimes in medical stuff is
when like you go through like what you
feel like is the brunt of it and then
you're like okay cool so how much more
and there's still [ __ ] on that that
happened to me with my ICL fee so if my
I sales my uh contact implant why'd you
have an implanted card yeah so it's like
it's so you like LASIK or ICL's the
other option so for me what they do they
put a little slice and they put pretty
much like a permanent hard contact in
there but to make sure that it moves
around and when you're like flying or if
you're like diving order but that to
regulate the pressure they put holes in
your iris just like three little holes
just saw the want the fluid can travel
back and forth and then so wait it's all
the hole still bare your soul is inside
the iris heal you know every girl you
got holes your eyes yes you see you know
you can actually
sometimes like you fund me at the right
angle you can see the girl so what it
feels like when they poked this hole in
her iris because I shoot it with the
laser it feels like someone getting a
rubberband and pull they do try to know
your eyes oh my god but a wax you're in
the IRA and the hurts like a
[ __ ] and then saw so how many of
these are we gonna have and he's like
usually three done okay cool yes I
sucked it up I did three and I'm like
oooh ho actually I've never really met
someone with such dark look you put
keeper chin on that thing please wait
didn't have your eyes pulled over you
little [ __ ] ever I would [ __ ] scream
I do you should have been like can I
like spread this over a whole year it is
more torture everyone they're like [ __ ]
how often you have to go back no it was
just that one time thank God that's a
nightmare you guys also feel like you
know this entire episode that we've been
talking about some like painful [ __ ] do
you actually like feel it in your body
when you're doing like when you're
hearing this or when you watch movies
and someone gets like their arm talk
talk or something like do you feel it in
your arm or am I [ __ ] weird no my
butthole gets really tight
well maybe something that I like I can
relate to yeah like if it's a guy that's
like Oh his chute ripped off his arm cuz
he was skydiving wrong I can't really I
can't tell but if it's like something
like eyeballs or teachers normals kicked
in the nuts see is nothing for me oh I
feel like all mine yeah that's why all
guys grab their balls when these watch
somebody get kicked yeah
well then like the video of the the pap
smear that I saw I was like I can't do
it a pap smear yeah really yeah cuz they
swab it your dude inside there with what
is basically a [ __ ] um I keep it
scraper iron straw cleaner like a straw
like oh no now they changed it it's not
every year anymore I really have
supposed to get it like I forgot already
I'm due for one though oh I should get
one see it's to check for like cancerous
cells I mean sort of like a weird oh
yeah anything yeah but like so like
stuff that I can't relate to I can't
really fit like my then even things that
I couldn't possibly really do like
getting shot or something like I feel it
like I feel like my skin black in the I
guess I'm watching wow I'm watching that
good empathy yeah I guess I don't know
but like I little pain upbeat payment
payment beep its baby my your eyeballs
and like I feel the sharp pain that
you're talking about in my eyeballs oh
my god God stop cuz I gots the reason
why I kind of want to shoot myself
sometimes just know what I know what it
feels like how would you do it my leg
like just should I would if my bones
don't have to shatter yeah raise the arm
my arm fat a little bit no like I would
want to know what it feels to go through
if it wasn't gonna kill me go through
bone - no not the bone of the bone
well if it did I want everything to go
back to normal
yes but that's the thing that doesn't
happen and the story you tell is stupid
it's not like I wasn't like some crazy
what if they develop some crazy like VR
kind of technology in the future where
we can experience things like pain wise
I will not spend money on that or not
pleasure like you know people already
are sex yeah but like but like pinion
our pleasure brain are you feeling so
it's not weird to your like brain waves
and then you can feel that's dangerous
because then if your brains experiencing
the pain you're actually experiencing
the pain yeah like an inception yeah Oh
whatever you believe I really if it's
like customizable we're like you can
choose what makes you feel good like
your parents actually saying they're
proud of you and stuff that would be
nice
that's a good VR world yeah yeah that'd
be the hardest in a program it would be
very test subjects for that right and
they're enough yeah sorry this can't
work on Asian Bo input your your
ethnicity first Asian sorry not example
they're like it's not realistic give me
a dump enjoy you gotta be our dreams
over I get shot in my back and I
actually feel like every single bullet
hole what about those like super cheesy
action films like that Theresa Shaw
million times do you feel the pain to
like how invested I am when like
listening to or watching it so it's a
bad movie then you go done really poorly
then probably not I probably can't feel
it that would be funny though if you're
just like oh
reviews movies like zero no 10 did not
feel the pavement
no no painted me they're gonna watch us
all yes that's all pain when he chops
off his foot in that first one I live
JIT my ankles like throbbing it hurt I
don't know why you get phantom I can't
do that with that [ __ ] weird
nothing just had a lot of empathy yes we
saw was a real thing and we were jigsaw
and we only did it to bad people that'd
be super that's what he does to people
that he views as being bad that would be
so fun
I would enjoy about like we can just
like heaven alone like that on my soul I
could it's mine cuz I deserve it
these are bad people yeah even if
they're bad were they bad bad I don't
want to throw human in case we're in an
article Oh like bad people like it was
like a this guy's soul this guy's a
[ __ ] rapist oh yeah you know like
Dexter style yeah and then we can have
like brainstorming like creativity to me
is so many ideas you know I think that's
what Jamali is for cheese oh because
years ago I would say like similar
remember I remember you guys asking me
like what if something happened Isaac
and this person that did something I'm
like oh [ __ ] yeah Tomer shreds but now
I'm like well she's New Testament of the
Bible now she's not loving Jesus not the
wrath all poured there but they [ __ ]
with my family so guess what you not a
people anymore really well things happen
to me too and I'm not an [ __ ] so ya
know for me if if someone raped my kid
first off you get scissors cut your
penis in half so it's hot dog yeah and
then we figure out what happened in your
past return the favor first
let's flop open you put like a handful
of salt in there you close it oh but
some people might like that better
yeah packing and a little bit of
mayonnaise like a sour cherry
[Music]
[Music]